what's the book about well the book it
sort of came from doing the podcast and
it's a book about about my unqualified
advice and my terrible theories that I
have on life and as I hope it's a book
that people read but it's probably a
book that nobody should read because my
like I I know nothing
your publisher hates you right now I
know but I love it should read this book
but I mean what kind of advice you
giving do you have a specific real
advice for you know how people yeah like
there's a chapter like you know
threesomes seems like a great idea right
you know and then I've like lifts my
thoughts right my thoughts about
threesomes which I don't in mic I don't
actually think it's a great idea believe
it or not but um one of the chapters is
men in professions you should not date
which starts off with magician you don't
think any woman should date a magician
if he's a magician it's just end it
right away
I just think someone who really enjoys
trick you like I enjoy a good magician
every now and again but just in my daily
life do you want somebody who's like I'm
not telling me my secret yeah I don't
know right try again knock it off and
then these tell me your secrets right
second is musician and less classical
except you don't want first chair first
chair is two is no offense
oh yeah I want to date all of you yeah
yeah I don't even know it hey many of
them aren't musicians
I won't say which ones but there's three
of them that it's really not good why
are you in the back yeah bomb is just
here yeah you knew a guy who knew a guy
he bangs coconuts together so so you
really do say like these are now who's
like a perfect more yeah I'm here more
location
well athlete not just because of the
potential you know the rumors of
cheating but because I think you'd have
to be like you know that rookies not so
good you know you there wouldn't be the
constant emotional like oh you but I
know you guys lost but you'll win next
like oh that seems like a big chore
right but this is oh that's what my wife
talks to me and I'm a comedian
well comedian yeah like also on the list
yeah we're a freak show should have been
number one what I think comedian should
be not going yeah I'm gonna revise it
yeah but yeah anyway chef I've got a
bunch of them chef wait a minute chef
seems like it would be perfect that's
shipping the guy that's like baby you're
home look I just made this great amazing
cool dish for you to eat you've just
entered the chef's trap that's what you
think right yeah but in my experience
watching Hell's Kitchen the kitchen
cultivates a like an environment of
anger anger into a you know and you get
it for me I think it's hard to just
leave it home right right your chef is
gonna bring home the temp right there's
gonna be a lot so it's not gonna make
you this great pasta every night and
there's gonna be a perfect perfect
poured glass of wine no he's just gonna
be smashed well often they come home at
like 4:00 in the morning right like oh
yeah I'll piss okay so what's your dream
guy who's the guy the only guy that you
can date is a as well as a woodworking
like a man guy who knows how to make
stuff a guy who knows how to make
specifically canoes and that's all
that's all that's all we got oars maybe
a small sailboat
yeah like Kevin Costner and
Nik offer ya nick offerman offerman
makes canoes he's happily married so
yeah you know anyway essentially there's
there's no one for us and i of course
not only have i not dated anybody on my
list right but i also violated one of
the you know the professional my list
which is an actor which is further down
but still on their right
you